أصدر رئيس الوزراء اللبناني ، صندل
هيريرا ، مجموعة من الإصلاحات
التي يأمل أن تهدئ موجة
الاحتجاجات التي اندلعت حول لبنان
منذ الأسبوع الماضي.
كما يتضمن البرلمان
ضريبة جديدة على أرباح البنوك التي من المأمول
أن تخفض عجز الميزانية السنوية ،
كما ستشمل تشكيل
لجنة ستحاول إعادة
ما يسمى بالأموال المنهوبة الموجودة الآن في
حسابات بنكية أجنبية ، وتعهد
بأن  ستحل الحكومة المشاكل
التي أوجدتها الخدمات العامة المتدهورة في لبنان ،
لكن يبدو أن
المتظاهرين لم يشتروا ذلك بعد
الخطاب في الواقع ذهب المزيد من الناس
للانضمام إلى المظاهرات في بيروت
والمدن اللبنانية الأخرى الذين تحدثنا
إليهم وقالوا إنهم ببساطة ليس لديهم إيمان ضئيل.  في
وعود السياسيين يبدو
أن الهوة بين الحكام
والمحكومين في لبنان تتسع ثم
نبدأ في  وبيروت